Clark County School police responding to
nearly 6 000 violent incidents since the
start of this school year and we have
more details about that here tonight
that's right those incidents range from
shootings to even attempted kidnappings
Joshua Pajero breaks down to schools
with the most arrests
ccsdpd from August of last year to
mid-February here is a map of the
schools with the most arrests you have
Miley achievement Center at eight Valley
High School at six Cheyenne and Legacy
at five and sunrise and the Soul Academy
at 4. the violence at Clark County
Schools was a focus at a hearing last
week in Carson City superintendent Dr
Jesus Jara said some of that violence is
due to living in urban America some of
the things that we are dealing with
today
it's been dealing with around Urban
America
that we are dealing with Community
issues and challenges that are coming
into the footsteps of our schools all
the Nevada schools superintendents as
well as the Clark County Education
Association are supporting legislation
to curtail the classroom violence the
number of firearms the number of violent
Behavior that's escalating indicates
something is about to happen school
police have seized more than 30 guns and
144 knives this school year alone last
week Republican Governor Joe Lombardo
spoke at Valley High to talk about
student violence and his efforts to
decrease it through his bill AB 330. we
know the tens of thousands of students
families and teachers have been
effective
even right here at Valley High School we
know that students and teachers have
been impacted by school violence while
there were students arrested for illegal
shootings and robberies there were 30
arrests for battery and assaults
followed by 29 arrests for fights and 23
for harassment and threats school police
also responded to 122 sexual assault
calls for service most were handled by
other agencies in a statement regarding
these stats by the Clark County
Education Association they say quote we
see the headlines every week about
horrific tragedies unfolding in schools
across the country and we can only ask
ourselves Will Clark County be next
simply put lawmakers must act now end
quote
CCSD did send us a statement regarding
the violent act reports which says in
part the report for calls for service do
not reflect the actual number of
incidents as multiple people may call
police for the very same event as
mandated CCSD employees are required to
report concerns about abuse or neglect
in the home those reports are reflected
in the report as well